I'm an adult female wearing a Top Gun
onesie that I bought off of Amazon you
know what that means
time for me to judge other people's
fashion hi guys my name is grace Helbig
if you don't know now you know your life
is different now the People's Choice
Awards happened the other night
okay first question what the [ __ ] are
the People's Choice Awards that's a Teen
Choice Award and then there's the
People's Choice Awards so that leads me
to believe that teens are not people how
do you become a people you just have to
participate enough that the network that
runs your work show makes money off of
your line participation got it cool
rural people
Jeffrey Lopez what the actual [ __ ] is
happening here you look like a Victorian
robot busting through a fifth Harmony's
circuit 2014 red carpet dress my cake is
done of course I'm making a cake right
now I'm people JLo more like Jeon no why
are you doing this to us why why are you
being so aggressively ageless to us I
hope that that's not actually like part
of the dress and you just got a chest
tattoo and joke on us you're too south
and we're all like wow how elegant
there's harmony oh my god this is the
first time the fifth harmony performed
as four members it looks like someone
put a satin sheet in the dryer with like
a bra and the bra like hook that tangled
on it and it just like wrapped up like
all in all of them and they're just they
all got part of it it looks a little bit
like they're all being Mariah Carey for
Halloween and also looks like you all
are about to go to sexy fleet at any
moment
cute you also kind of look like more sad
than I've seen you in photos so you guys
okay Blake Lively look at you look at
you your mom what are you doing with
these award shows what did you win why
are you then what did you win I very
much appreciate the fact that you're
like doing the hair I don't have time
for this just make sure my legs are
shiny you look glowy and mommy like your
vagina seem some [ __ ] but it doesn't
stop you cue Victoria Justice Victoria
justice victoria justice or this mean
endo victorian justice justice is served
this is very I went to Michael's and
diys necklace for myself and actually
turned out into a full-on ensemble when
you get those hair beads in your hair
but like no no put it on with it cute
Priyanka Chopra
you're just a peach dream right now what
is what's happening here there's I got
beautiful ace bandage that someone
didn't wrap properly Ruby Rose no ah
when women do pant suits well I lose my
fishing line so if you'd like to be part
of the search party for my mind I have
signups happening because this is not
fair you look like sexy ketchup sera
cha-cha-cha-cha-cha
Kristen Bell I feel like you want us to
look at your breasts I can't confirm
this is studio 54 happening and then you
got two little breast of it I appreciate
the acknowledgement of various eras of
history Candace Cameron Bure aka DJ
Tanner from full house / fuller house I
mean it looks a little bit like a
housewife that put the vacuum in Reverse
and blew her hair away I like it very
very much a job Candace Cameron Bure oh
are you religious Aaron Burr I just been
talking about all right Cameron Dallas
Oh given us that maybe Spanish maybe
Matador I took the scarf over the socks
matte black look I kind of like this
I like when guys do something different
than a suit on a red carpet so I think
this is kind of cool huh nice mine like
that I'm been doing it I can't do that
this is my side no and then it turns
into Robert Niro can't stop it I'll stop
it
Dave Coulier because the entire cast of
fuller house is there did Coulier look
cool hey I didn't mean that as a
Canadian jobs it like good job you look
cool you look like
like an uncle that I got a makeover on a
TLC reality show and we're all proud of
you really saying how dare you you look
gorgeous great dress great color
your skin looks amazing your makeup
looks flawless your hair looks fantastic
you're not overdoing it but here's the
best part of this photos I get most of
my photos from eonline because they just
have really good red-carpet coverage
they said is Lily Singh's description
bad mom Starr certainly doesn't have a
bad look for this evenings affair
rocking this awesome Nicole Miller
something-something dress you know
classic only thing one of the stars with
bad mom no other credit because we hate
the Jim englishmatt and refuse to
acknowledge it hey les the girl from the
thing and the spouse it was a really
Coachella version of a Plinko board and
start out I'm all for that baby area
baby I believe it's a musically person
buying our prices overall general
internet person you look good at girl
get it she's from the world wide web but
if you look at this ensemble you can
tell that she's really representing the
net okay that's it that's it for my
review of the People's Choice Awards red
carpet fashions I hope you guys enjoyed
this if you did give it a thumbs up and
let me know who you enjoyed the most on
the red carpet of the single Choice
Awards and click the fun here and
subscribe to this youtube channel
because i mean is not the worst thing
you've ever seen in your life
i've ever seen like people giving birth
to children this is not that thank you
guys so much for spending down here I
really appreciate it I don't know you
know what happens when we give people a
choice go-gurt that's what happens
go-gurt happens